I want you to change the particle demo a little. Instead of 8,000 particles
placed at random, I want you to create 9,261 particles in a highly structured
grid. Rewrite the point generation part of the code to place a particle at
every point in a 2,000 by 2,000 by 2,000 unit grid centered around the origin,
spaced 100 units apart. In other words, you'll want to a point at x, y, z
equals negative 1,000, negative 1,000, negative 1,000, x, y, z negative 900,
1,000, 1,000 and so on throughout the grid in all directions up to point x, y,
z 1,000, 1,000, 1,000. There are 21 points you'll place along any given axis.
This should add up to 9,261 points, which is 21 times 21 times 21. When you're
done you should see this on the screen. I've turned the background color to
gray so that it's easier to see the particles themselves.